The joe rogan experience.
So I'm a woman who is into nice clothes
and nice nails.
No,
I didn't say he's into.
And you can tell by the type,
the type,
but what is the type the guy should look
out for?
If you're a like you are going to give a
seminar how?
Gosh should avoid nightmare horrible
women in their life,
which should they avoid.
Okay.
You okay?
First of all,
it's a case by case basis.
There's plenty different horrible
things.
Of course,
if she's got big old French tip nails,
she's a little bit of white trash.
Okay.
Friendship nails are bad.
Like long press on French tip nails.
What if they're real nails?
They're French.
Touch tip is,
to me it's just such a trashy book,
but that's fine.
Okay.
I don't know.
Um,
what about like dark red,
like Spanish girl with red lipstick and
dark red nails?
It depends on the girl.
It's a whole package because you can
have trashy elements like I'm wearing
cut off jeans right now in a see through
tank top.
That's what I'm talking about.
But it's ready to judge you.
But the rest of me is not polished.
It's not like the rest I've got like
messy hair and one foot painted.
Is that okay?
It's okay because I'm like not trying.
Okay.
I think it's just,
there's just certain looks that women
have and I don't want to say,
oh,
it's this hairdo.
It's that.
It's a whole,
and you know what I'm talking about.
It's a whole myriad of elements that
come together.
Does she have,
and there's nothing wrong with having
like enhancements.
Does she have fake lips and fake tits
and hair extensions and claws?
Andy,
she weren't stripper heels.
Well then she's probably fucking
horrible.
Like let's get serious lucite heels like
indoors.
That's pretty rare though,
isn't it?
I mean we're with some pretty extreme
examples.
I don't even know what realm we're
dealing with.
The fake lip thing is a,
that's a crazy one too.
Like they never really worked that out
in so many girls jumped on that
bandwagon.
Excuse me,
jumped on that bandwagon.
They fucked up their face forever.
I think women in Hollywood make a
decision.
They were like,
I would rather look super weird that
look super old because when you like a
lot of them you can't tell what they
are,
how old they are.
This is so weird.
There's this woman that I see at my
daughter's school when I drop my kid off
in the morning and cheese.
It makes me sad because this lady,
she,
she looked like she was probably pretty
when she was younger and she's not that
old.
She's probably in her late thirties
maybe early forties but she has turned
her face into that a monster,
a monster and there's no going back.
It's rubber,
it doesn't move.
It's frozen.
It's filled in in weird ways where it
looks like she's got a fucking tooth
ache or something like her face is
swollen and she,
you know what the kicker is?
She might've gone in for one thing,
had a weird reaction or whatever and
like now it's like that and she might be
a super cool lady or something and
that's just like,
like you're stuck with,
well you know what I think it is.
I think it's a dysmorphia.
Yeah.
Like the same thing where anorexics
habit bodybuilders have it.
Women who have a boob implants a lot of
times never think their boob implants
are big enough.
They want to keep going and going and
going and getting bigger and bigger.
They get,
they get crazy,
they'll look at them and they're like
not big enough like they,
they don't see what everyone else is
seeing.
What we were talking about before about
mma,
I think it's still in a learning period.
I think we still haven't got it down the
way.
Like say football has it down,
they know exactly how to train to
develop like top flight football
players,
basketball,
same thing.
You go to a basketball camp,
you're dealing with top flight strength
and conditioning coach.
They really know how to deal with,
I mean there you're dealing with multi
multimillion dollar athletes and they
have that investment and they want to
keep it healthy and really no one should
apply that more than MMA fighters
because who the fuck gets hurt more than
MMA fighters?
Whiteside and Woodside
probably is the worst taught sport in
the world,
especially in Thailand because there's
no history of teaching.
So it was like a is teaching fighters
would they just copied by osmosis
pretty.
So it was like,
that's one of the posts backwards sports
in the world.
Everyone della Mae and isn't a lot of
smoking and drinking as well.
We had
better,
like they've gotten a lot of um,
you know,
fight against alcohol,
flight gets drugs.
This is a lot of promotion.
Now you've got a lot of guys like
[inaudible] Mallett pedal.
He's actually American,
um,
you know,
add [inaudible] and these guys are
heroes.
So for people there's a lot more push
towards the be healthy,
get fit.
You could make good money.
Now go to Japan,
you can fight in American dude dives.
Yeah.
I have friends that,
that trained in font in Thailand and
they were telling me about everybody
smoking cigarettes.
And I have my friend Chris started
smoking when he was in Thailand because
he's fighting,
he's fighting in Thailand.
Everybody was training and smoking and
he starts smoking too.
Just like to be one of those gangs right
now.
He smoked cigarettes,
you know Cha Champa cat,
some grit,
you know,
I've heard the name,
he's already like Tom Post sort of base
where we were.
Oh really?
Yeah,
we broke rick,
Rufus,
his leg.
You've seen the fight.
I'm sure you're the one who when he puts
him in the,
and he breaks his leg the fall.
I didn't see that.
It's on youtube.
It's worth watching.
But we saw him and he's a,
he's a legend before Andy Hook for all
these cars.
Right.
We go to Thailand and Petaja and he's
just sitting there smoking.
So if I buy him a box of cigarettes,
he'll let me film him kicking the bag.
So just bring a box of cigarettes and he
kicked the bag for me.
Show me the technique,
you know,
like they're just smoking and alcohol
over there is out of control.
Wow.
There at the moment,
being on the top of it in industry,
especially in an industry that's
involved in technology is a very
precarious position.
You know,
if you talked to,
um,
Kodak a decade ago,
do you think they would,
they would realize that suddenly it's
the largest vendor or manufacturer of
cameras in the world would be a
telephone company.
Nokia,
within three years became the world's
largest maker of cameras and suddenly
the entire industry changed.
Right.
And how do you compete against that?
They're not even in your industry.
They just came out of left field.
It's like you're suddenly the horse
buggy manufacturer and Ford is taking
your business and you never expected
that was going to happen.
Well Nokia has a,
has a
camera phone now,
a windows phone that is some insane
amount of pixels.
It's like 40 fucking megapixels or
something.
Some crazy 41 41 megapixel says Jamie.
Jamie is on top of that shit.
41 fucking megapixels on a phone.
I mean this thing I think has of the
note three,
I think it has 12 or something.
You know,
it's better than that.
Are you familiar with Moore's law?
Yes.
So,
so for,
for your listeners to Moore's law,
it was created by Gordon Moore,
pro processors,
right?
Processing speed.
And yeah,
and what he said was that he estimated
that because of the way silicon works,
every 18 months,
the speed of a computer with double or
the price would drop by half.
And that has been true now for more than
25 years.
Wow.
And,
and that thing then plays out in camera
megapixels,
in storage on SD cards,
in the size of the,
of your smartphone,
in the,
a number of sensors you can put into the
smartphone.
And it's battery.
Battery life is the one that's lagging
behind.
And it's the main thing that's holding
back this technology.
Moore's law also applies to things like
bitcoin.
It also applies to networks like the
Internet.
And what it means is that if you're in
an industry that's established and
suddenly you have a competitor that's
coming at you with the power of Moore's
law,
you better watch out because you're in,
it's not a matter of whether you will be
able to compete in a decade.
It's a matter of whether your industry
will still exist in a decade.
Right?
Yeah.
Isn't that fascinating?
That whole industries can just vanish
hundred and 50 years of Kodak and then
suddenly film doesn't exist.
God,
okay.